good morning John I don't know say it
with me I don't know God it is
liberating I am a towering mountain of
ignorance I don't know why is a plumber
named Mario Mario are the most well
known videogame character in existence
nor know why our guitar is shaped like
this why is Iggy Azalea popular good
lord I have no idea I think then I know
a lot of things though when I play pub
trivia with my friends I'm surprisingly
unhelpful but the vast majority of
things vast majority I don't know and
not just because of the sheer number of
things but also the number of things
that effect those things we live in an
age where we're taught to believe that
everything has a reason so we observe
the world we see what happened and then
we define the thing that happened as the
reason the thing happened we say Harry
Potter is popular because it took place
in a school and it was well written and
we had a deep and unknown desire for
silly wizards which is the exact same
thing as saying Harry Potter is popular
because it's Harry Potter and then we
think we solved it and then when other
books about wizards in schools that are
well written come out were like well
it's not Arry but yeah so it doesn't
have all the attributes of Harry Potter
so it's not as popular as Harry Potter
we're really good at this now I'm glad
that we have the desire to understand
the world that results in all sorts of
great stuff you want to know everything
we're humans we're curious and maybe
it's our culture maybe it's just
humanity I think a lot of the time we
end up mixing up thinking something with
knowing something suddenly it's kind of
expected that everyone the world has an
opinion on how to solve the Syrian civil
war and how to create more jobs in the
United States and what are the effects
of cellphone use on the youth of today I
know that I don't know but somehow
everyone else seems to know I'll know
differently from each other but they all
seem to know when you look at all deeply
at this you realize that people aren't
basing their opinions on what they think
is the best course of action or the
actual best explanation for it they're
basing it on their values and that's
fine so what values are foreign values
are great it might be a little silly to
think that you've discovered the best
possible course of action just because
you figured out a way to turn your
values into an executable vision now
these guesses are useful tremendously
useful we we convert
Amalgamated opinions in debt like
reality that's the terrifying beauty of
culture and more specifically democracy
but they are just guesses no one knows
the correct course of action we will
never take it because there are too many
options well I'm saying is nobody's
opinions are correct in the world and
yet it's impossible not to tie your
opinions to your concept of self often
people tie those things so closely
together that they begin defending their
guesses is if they're defending their
very lives in a way they are this is why
it can be so impossible to talk about
certain topics with certain people
they've tied those sub positions to
themselves so tightly with knots of
narrative and constructed reality and
values that there's just no untying it
maybe unsurprisingly in those situations
the best course of action is just to be
friends maybe even ask them about that
thing that they've created because to
them as it is to all of us it's
immensely valuable the world as we
perceive it as we've built it inside of
ourselves is a lie that we tell to
ourselves not out of deception but out
of necessity we have no other choice we
simply cannot understand the world as it
is and so we construct and it's a useful
construction and it allows us to do many
amazing things but sometimes I just have
to tell myself the thing that is
definitely true the truest thing I can
say which is that I don't know I don't
know I don't know John I'll see you on
Tuesday and often people tie those
things so closely together the dip so
closely together that they're so closely
together the RISM so closely together
that they depend so closely together
that that today they after that today